vamos a resolver más problemas y este en
particular es un problema clásico si
brit tiene dos dólares con 25 centavos
en monedas de 5 y 10 centavos si ella
tiene 40 monedas en total cuántas
monedas de cada tipo ella tiene bueno
vamos a establecer algunas variables
aquí digamos que n va a ser el número de
monedas que valen 5 centavos y vamos a
definir a la letra d como el número de
monedas de 10 centavos ahora que tenemos
definidas las variables vamos a expresar
lo que sabemos y lo que sabemos es que
la cantidad de dinero que se recaba
entre ambos tipos de monedas es igual a
2 dólares con 25 centavos así que si yo
multiplico el número de monedas de 5
centavos por la cantidad de dinero que
representan x 0.05 que esto es la
cantidad de dinero representado solo por
las monedas de 5 centavos
el número de monedas de 10 centavos
multiplicadas por 0.1 que es 10 centavos
lo que representa todo esto la suma de
esto debe ser igual a 2 dólares con 25
centavos no confundir a en ella de con
el dinero que representan n iv d son
solo el número de monedas que se tienen
de cierto tipo y el total debe ser igual
a 2 dólares con 25 centavos así que esta
primera parte de nuestro de nuestro
problema ya lo hemos representado aquí
en esta sección en la cantidad de
monedas que se tienen deben de ser igual
a 2.25 el número de monedas de 25
centavos más el número de monedas de 10
centavos debe ser igual a 40 monedas esa
es la segunda parte de nuestro problema
y esta la tenemos todavía que
representar como otra ecuación en
términos de estas variables que ya
definimos y vamos a escribir esta otra
ecuación con un color diferente ahora
escribimos que el número de total de
monedas de 5 y 10 centavos
va a ser igual a 40 monedas n de igual a
40 y ahora tenemos dos ecuaciones con
dos incógnitas tenemos un sistema de
ecuaciones y lo que vamos a hacer ahora
es sustituir una de estas variables
despejada de una de las fórmulas de
manera que nos quede una ecuación en
términos de una sola incógnita de esta
ecuación de aquí abajo vamos a despejar
nuestra variable de y la vamos a
sustituir en la otra ecuación así que
aquí vamos a restar m en ambos lados de
la ecuación
- n - n y nos queda de igual a 40 menos
m ahora tomamos este valor de de y lo
vamos a sustituir en la ecuación de
arriba y para que quede más claro vamos
a poner esto en color verde señalando
que va a ser sustituido aquí
reescribimos esta ecuación y nos queda
0.05 por n más
0.1 por d pero en este caso de es 40
menos m para hacer congruentes vamos a
cambiar el color vamos a poner aquí el
valor de de en verde así que escribimos
40 menos n y ahora tenemos una ecuación
en términos de cuántas monedas de 5
centavos tenemos que todo esto debe ser
igual a 2.25 y ahora nos toca
simplificar así que tenemos 0.05 n + 0.1
por 40 va a ser 4 y para ser congruentes
vamos a escribirlo también en verde
entonces es 4 menos 0.1 por n que lo
único que hicimos fue distribuir este
0.1 multiplicando por los elementos
dentro del paréntesis y todo esto debe
ser igual a 2.25 y ahora lo que nos
queda hacer es agrupar los términos de m
tenemos 0.05 n menos 0.1
0.10 n nos va a quedar menos 0.05 m ya
que menos 0.10 más 0.05 es menos 0.05 y
continuamos más 4 igual a 2.25 y ahora
quitamos 4 en ambos lados de la ecuación
y nos queda menos 0.05 m igual a 2.25
menos 4 nos va a quedar menos 1.75
tenemos menos 0.05 n igual a menos 1.75
podemos multiplicar todo por menos 1 y
ahora nos va a quedar 0.05 n igual a
1.75 finalmente dividimos ambos lados de
esta ecuación entre 0.05 aquí va a ser 1
1.75 entre 0.05 y
finalmente n va a ser igual a 1.75 /
0.05 vamos a hacer la división más a
detalle lo escribimos aquí 0.05 va a
dividir a 1.75 bueno analizamos y vemos
que tenemos dos decimales después del
punto decimal así que vamos a recorrer
nuestro punto dos lugares hacia la
derecha y esto es lo mismo que dividir
175 entre 53 por 5 15 aquí lo escribimos
17 menos 15
quedan 2 bajamos el 5 25 entre 5 pues
ese 55 por 525 lo restamos nos queda 0 y
y va a ser igual a 35 así que tenemos 35
monedas de 5 centavos y ahora lo que nos
queda es sustituir este valor para
encontrar las monedas de 10 centavos por
lo que ve va a ser igual a 5 así que
finalmente podemos decir que tenemos 5
monedas de 10 centavos y 35 monedas de 5
centavos vamos a revisar los valores
recuerden que siempre es importante
verificar los resultados vamos a ver
aquí lo ponemos esto es 35 0.5 por 35 va
a ser igual a 1.75
en este otro vamos a sustituir la de por
el valor 50 punto 10 por 5 es igual a
punto 5 si sumo 1.70 y 5.5 va a ser
igual a 2.25 verificando nuestro
resultado ahora vamos a resolver un
problema más a continuación se muestran
unas figuras que tienen una combinación
de cuadrados que tienen cierto patrón
cuántos cuadrados estarán en el diagrama
número 12 bueno vamos a analizar esto
este es el primer diagrama este es el
segundo diagrama y este el tercer
diagrama aquí vemos que sólo hay un
cuadrado un cuadrado solito aquí tenemos
dos cuadrados por dos y falta que un
cuadrado en esquina
no anotamos acá y vamos a seguir
revisando
aquí tenemos 3 x 3 y falta un cuadrado
de 2 x 2
si continuamos aquí siguiendo el patrón
serían 4x4 y faltaría un cuadrado de 3 x
me parece que una manera de describir el
número de cuadrados sería que de hecho
sería la forma más fácil es ver que si
aquí tenemos tres y aquí tenemos tres
menos uno sería dos pero bueno mejor
vamos a ponerlo en otro color para que
quede más claro 3 - 1 quedan 2 aquí
tengo 2 y 2 menos uno queda uno y aquí
solo tengo uno aquí de este otro lado no
tengo nada tengo cero así que la forma
de poder describir este patrón de
cuadrados es que si tengo n como el
número de cuadrados verticales más el
número de cuadrados horizontales que es
n
1 todo esto va a ser igual a 2 n menos
uno
de esta manera expresamos en forma de
ecuación el patrón de cuadrados de este
ejercicio 3 +
3 - 1 son dos es 32 15 así que si n es
igual a 12 2 por 12 menos 1 va a ser
igual a
4 - 1 23 23 cuadrados 23 cuadrados
tendrá nuestro diagrama número 12 vamos
a hacer otro problema nuestro último
problema de hoy
grace comienza a usar su bicicleta a una
velocidad de 12 millas por hora una hora
después dan comienza a usar su bicicleta
a 15 millas por hora siguiendo la misma
ruta cuánto tiempo le tomará a adam
alcanzar a grace bueno vamos a escribir
nuestras variables que va a ser el
tiempo que va a estar grace usando la
bicicleta
aunque pensándolo bien lo mejor que te
sea el tiempo en el que dan está usando
la bicicleta el tiempo en el que dan usa
la bicicleta y sabemos que el tiempo que
grace estuvo usando la bicicleta es el
tiempo que la uso dan más una hora así
que escribimos de más uno es igual al
tiempo que grace uso la bicicleta pues
dan comenzó a usar la bicicleta una hora
después de que lo hizo grace entonces ya
tenemos definidos el tiempo de edad y el
tiempo de grace que el tiempo de grace
es 1
más que el verano ahora la distancia
está definida como la velocidad por el
tiempo así que comenzamos con la
distancia de dan va a ser igual a 15
millas por hora por el tiempo que se
tarda en usar la bicicleta 15 deporte y
la distancia de grace le vamos a
escribir aquí vamos a ponerla en otro en
otro color para que se note el verde es
de grace la distancia de grace es igual
a 12 millas por hora que su velocidad de
su ruta por el tiempo pero el tiempo de
grace recordemos que este más 1 y lo que
queremos saber es en qué momento estas
dos distancias son iguales en qué
momento dan alcanza a grace
y para eso necesitamos saber qué valor
de t va a hacer que estos dos estos dos
elementos sean iguales 15 t
va a ser igual bueno 15 t es el tiempo
que han estado usando la bicicleta va a
ser igual a 12 por temas uno que es el
tiempo que grace ha estado usando la
bicicleta y acuérdense que grace ha
estado una hora más en la bicicleta
quedan
entonces escribimos 15 t igual a 12 x de
12 t más 12 por uno va a ser más 12 y
ahora vamos a restar 12 t en ambos lados
de la igualdad pues lo que nos queda
3 t igual a 12 dividimos ambos lados
entre 3 y nos queda que t es igual a 12
entre 3 va a ser igual a 4 aquí lo
escribimos de igual a 4 este es el
tiempo de edad así que después de que
cuatro horas estuvo dan en la bicicleta
fue que alcanzó a grace
y el tiempo de grace fue el tiempo de
dar más una hora así que fueron cinco
horas y para conocer la distancia vamos
a poner a multiplicar 4 por 15 fueron la
distancia 60 millas las que recorrió dan
y para verificar que es la misma
distancia en la que recorrió grace
multiplicamos 12 por 4 + 1 ó 12 por 5
aquí lo escribimos 5 por 12 el resultado
también va a ser igual a 60 millas por
lo que ambas distancias son iguales así
que después de recorrer 60 millas ambos
se van a encontrar